[Music]
[Music]
good evening everybody i'm theo
agnostopoulos and i would like to
welcome you in the panel who owns
science
have you ever had a stomach ache that
you had to look up in the internet
what could be the possible causes of
your symptoms
have you ever
thought whether you should eat
genetically modified corn
and wanted to look up for some
information
have you ever
looked up again for information to see
what would happen
is there any side effects of the covered
19 vaccine
these are all examples
of
people trying to access science this is
going to be a little bit of what we're
going to talk about here tonight
but also we're going to talk about
inclusivity
about the generation of fake news about
patents and about how we can engage
citizens in science policy
but let's take things from the beginning
as i said and i'm i'm theo and i'm very
honored to be here um for this panel
which is
cognized by the bayer foundation and
psycho
but
for this
panel um we have
a lineup of three superstars
um and i would like to start by
introducing them
with um a professor of sociology
in fact she's the professor of sociology
at humboldt university berlin
she's also the president of berlin
social science center
and amongst the tens of honors and
awards that i could see in her cv i've
decided to just talk about mention a
couple of them
which are relevant to um this evening's
talk in fact one of them is relevant the
other one is a little bit irrelevant
but um we'll see
the relevant one she's a member of the
g7 gender equality advisory council by
the you gave a uk government
the less relevant one is that she's a
member of the pontifical academy of
social sciences
by the holy father
so let's welcome professor yuta
albendinger
thank you
[Applause]
now
we have another very inspiring young
lady with us
um who is a leader in her field she is
running she's a chemist she had always
had a passion for chemistry
um
and she's running her own group at
leibniz institute for catalysis
she used to be a competitive swimmer and
all that
really
okay it's a pity we don't have a
swimming pool here tonight
um
but uh
and all that passion uh she's taking it
into science
um she also loves to teach and train the
trainers other teachers
in in chemistry in stem education so
let's welcome yola pospech
[Applause]
doctor i forgot to mention
um
and last but not least um
we have a scientist with us who is um
quite accomplished he has more than
70 publications himself um including
once in nature and science before taking
up um the head of research and
innovation in several
companies
and he's currently the head of barrier
pharma research and development and a
lecture of biotechnology
at etihar zurich so let's welcome dr
christian rommel
[Applause]
so um with this panel um
we can start our discussion today but
before that i would like to share
something from my experience as a
science engager of the last 12 years
as i said earlier i've been running
psycho since 2008 and nine for the first
10 years of the life of this
organization
i had to explain to everybody why it is
important to communicate science
people were always telling me oh this is
so cool what are you doing so nice with
the kids with oh it's very very nice it
was always a bonus
it was never something really important
until
this catastrophe the disaster of covets
came
all of a sudden
what we were doing became
extremely important
and it's no surprise that in april 2020
this article came in the new york times
where
basically for the first time i could see
we could see the scientists as being the
superheroes
and why did this happen because in in
eras of crisis everybody needs a hero
somebody who's reliable somebody who who
knows what they're talking about
and some somebody who is a leader
so this transformation was a
transformation for our work as well
so
with this the next light please um
let me
let me say it again
corvid has been is a catastrophe okay
but let's try and see some positive
sides into all this
what happened
in the in the field of health
we now call it the health age because of
the mega transformations that took place
throughout these the last two years
so i would like to ask our panelists um
if you if i give you a minute
each
um
could you come out with a positive
outcome for science and one positive
outcome for you personally
um throughout the covet era and i will
start with uh utah
well uh positive thank you very much for
this very nice introduction and sorry
that you lost your bonus
so the positive side for science of
course you know is that people around
the civil society understand much more
why so much money spent for science and
why we need to finance long time basic
research i mean this is very very
obvious
second very very obvious thing is that
we quit that we need good science
communicators and that science is not
science but that we need to have
a discourse between the sciences it's
not just health sciences it's also
sociology it's also psychology it's also
a quite different impact on diff of
different parts
of the society and for me personally is
that i met
more of my neighbors than ever before
whether this is for good or for bad but
this is what happened
thank you and i was asked for many many
favors which i would never have asked
before as well
thanks joella
um
sorry uh yola yeah so for me uh
what was uh yeah really nice to see is
that i've never heard the term science
or scientists more often in public radio
or on television i don't have a
television but i assume it was pretty
frequently mentioned there too
and so that was cool as a since i'm a
scientist myself
um and also considering the years before
like
climate change came into
the focus of more and more people
which was actually
my biggest childhood fear i was always
afraid that the polar caps will may melt
and then
we will all
drown maybe that's why i learned
swimming
at an early age
but
yes in
2019 the climate movement was
so strong and
in 2020 you looked into the sky and see
i didn't barely see any plane and i
loved that
yeah that was a major transformation
in people's behavior at least
temporarily temporarily
we'll see yeah
christian please
yeah so
similarly the momentum we have right now
right in the dialogue the society about
uh medical innovation and in science uh
i hope we really as there is a saying
let's not have a good crisis to go to
waste
is that we can really capture this
the other one for us is
that we've seen unprecedented
partnership between
the
health agencies the openness to
advance and approve medicines ever
faster we see partnership between
competitors
that we have become collaborators in the
industry because of the need in the
urgency
we have now experienced that the power
of we call this decentralized clinical
trials where the patients go the
medicine goes to the patients and it's
not inviting the patients to come to a
medical center
the digital part of this i think we
really in i would think in an i wouldn't
say it's a revolution but there is so
much now going on that we can harness
and harvest for for the future is
tremendous
on a personal level
you learn a lot about the importance of
community and personal interaction
when you are
interacting virtually i think
there are a lot of good stuff but i
think also a lot of us misses few things
and i hope we carry them
forward and we install a sense of
personal interactions and one example is
when you go on such virtual zoom calls
and you say hey guys and everybody
should speak up and then everybody
please go mute
and and i think this is common behavior
you have an interest in someone sort but
there's something intrinsically actually
seeing go and mute and there's a lot of
reflection in learning how we work with
each other i think
yeah thank you thank you christian and
um with regards to the first part that
you mentioned this is also a um a
personal feeling
um
i was reading that similarly to the cold
era uh the cold war back in the 60s and
70 that all that race at the time
created a lot of innovation in the field
of um of the space
um industry
and
the the last two years have been called
the the health era because of all this
transformation that you mentioned which
is here to stay
hopefully so um okay thank you um let's
move on to to our first game um of this
uh evening
basically you will it's called guested
data we will show you data from the
survey of the euro barometer
this is a survey conducted by the
european union funded by the european
union it's the latest version the
results came out two months ago
the base is 37 000 people
all across europe all 27 eu countries
plus 11 more countries
the age group is above 16 and there's no
bias on to who um replies to those so
this
this survey is going to show us some
perceptions
and some
beliefs about science understanding
so uh in the first slide
i'm going to um
all of the statements you're going to
see are all true they're all correct i
would like our panelists to guess the
percentage of people who answered
correctly okay
so let me start with the first one which
is
the continents on which we live have
been moving for millions of years and we
can continue to move in the future
um so christian
what percentage uh people of people
answered this correctly do you think
every other one maybe 50 percent
andorran
it's 82 percent and you can see the the
voting of 2005 to the same question was
86
this year was 82 percent
um
so
uh
okay
you did relatively well on this one but
but uh hopefully i will give you another
chance um
you're very polite too um
now yola humans did not live at the same
time as the dinosaurs
how many answered this correctly
depends on whom you deserve consider a
dinosaur but
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i would hope for like the ones we
have in the museum
yeah yeah i'd love to see them and 90
percent
yeah that's quite hopeful um
so that means
34
um
of the people in europe they they
believe that
dinosaurs are pets you know
it's amazing um
if it wasn't such a strong uh survey i
would doubt the this data but it is very
reliable um
okay let's
go to
utah the oxygen we breathe comes from
from plants
80 percent exactly it's 82
don't get over excited
okay
christian
antibiotics do not kill viruses
hmm
60
55
um well done that was very close and i
would like to give the last question to
um to utah because of the type of the uh
of the question he says
i'm sorry ola um the methods used by the
natural sciences and the social sciences
are equally scientific
low number 40 at maximum oh you've seen
the survey before
it's 47 well done
okay um actually so
this is just a little bit of an
introduction yes this is what i know
because everybody told me that i'm not
working scientifically
well
okay so this is a perception that uh i
think that uh
there needs to be work done on this
right
well in general but well it it well yeah
it relates to both okay
so uh the the reason we did this
exercise is of course we introduce
gamification in our in our panel but
also this is a the next um uh
slide we want to basically discuss uh
mostly which is what maya interrupted
choice and the huge differences across
countries and by uh age and and things
like this um i cannot tell you about
about age but i can tell you that there
are differences and this is a good um
opportunity for me to tell you that for
example my country uh greece and also
cyprus they were the two worst ones in
the perception of antibiotics um
we were like 80 percent uh
that um
what was the question again um
antibiotics don't kill viruses yeah so
it was like um so basically we have this
culture we had this culture of taking
antibiotics as pills for everything and
this shows in this um so uh yes there
are differences between countries it's
it's a very extensive survey they've
done okay let's go to the following
slide um now who
answered correctly
who answered correctly in the previous
questions and this is this is going to
lead us to a discussion about
inclusivity
of science so
all these are summaries these i'm going
to read them through these are summaries
of how they answered
um
and i will explain exactly how they
answered but it was mainly a respondent
who used the internet frequently
they were right
uh mostly right it was respondents who
left education later more educated
people
it was
uh people who were relatively wealthy
they didn't have any difficulty paying
their bills
it was
people who had a prior interest in
science and technology
there were managers
white-collar workers students and
self-employed people
and men
now let me be a little they have more
time than women
yeah that's um
that's true i would like to be a little
bit more specific about how these
answers came up so for the example of
men
men are more likely than women to give
more than eight correct answers of the
of the total 11 questions and the
difference was 29
versus 19
but still
men scored higher than women
yeah but what does this mean a very
correct answer now we are really
approaching the topic yeah yeah do they
really have to guess the exact
percentage no they have all of us would
be wrong then you're right you have
these levels of um very much
um you know this is one to five
basically okay are the answers so five
is the the closest one um
uh
and
you know what i mean do you know what i
mean five categories categories with the
highest one
okay so let's discuss a little bit about
the these um these um uh
outcomes
and i would like to start with you um i
will all give you about two minutes each
to to express your opinions about this
topic and and then
we'll see how it goes please
um
well uh i have questions to all of them
actually because respondents who use the
internet every day then the question is
what kind of internet resources do they
use i mean are they social networks are
they uh wikipedia stuff or are those
newspapers i mean this is a really a
really fussy category yeah you're right
uh coincidentally we've inserted another
slide later on where they show us
uh where do they get this okay so uh
next one not surprising because the
longer you are in education the more you
learn from science and of science
no
surprise about this response so never
almost have difficulty paying this is
very much connected to education the
more education you have on average the
more earning capacities you have then of
course interest is related to knowledge
no question about this managers is also
calling you with the other ones and men
do have more time
it was under two minutes
okay
thank you i will
not related to education it's related to
time
it because many are covered more by most
of the studies compared to women
okay
no no i mean that's they know that i i
was i will come back to you i would like
to ask yola's a view on this because you
you're you're a
you leading your group you're into
science yourself
i don't know whether you want to do a um
answer on this exact very um to comment
on these results so you want to talk
about your personal experience
um of being
being assigned a female scientist um
i have one question concerning this so
correct answer i mean say guest right
yeah okay so in those five categories
yeah so i don't
feel that the term correct is correct
yeah so um yes the role of uh men and
women in science um of course is yeah
very pressing a question it has to
change so we are born 50 50 men and
women and then um through the um if we
rise through the ranks then
the decline of female co-workers is
eminent so
if we
now
i'm an assistant professor and we have
like a team meetings in the liveness
institute
and sometimes i look through the room
and like there are 20 people in there
and i'm the only woman
so
this is a little strange right now
actually in my lab we have
i have six
co-workers and five of them are women
so this is awesome
most of the time so we have
six
yeah six female co-workers and one man
and then the response is often like oh
this poor guy so you need to hire a man
next
but
um this is actually the normal
percentage in reverse so um
and signs out of
seven
persons six are
male
and nobody says oh you need to increase
the percentage of female coworkers and
they
the woman might
feel
discriminated um and
now yeah people are telling me this oh
this poor guy and actually he's a very
strong personality and is also for me
it's very important for him that he
never feels discriminated and i also
communicate that in reverse like so
when i started my group
i also always said there are no genders
in the group so we are all just people
that enjoy science and
everything else has second priority
and
i wish that for but this is a general
population or it's not
um
christian
well i
i think it triggers concerns
first if you know if you talk about
the education of science and innovation
medicine we talk about covet 19 and new
vaccines and half of the people believe
you you lift your co-existence with
dinosaurs i mean what a gap to fill
the other one is it doesn't represent
equality and i think it's a huge concern
if education is linked to
you know your financial situation to
whether you uh where you were born and
how you worry i mean this is
profound in such a simple access of
information
so i'll take a lot of concerns
from that i have to say
i see
fake news probably brexit if the
internet is a source of education and
whatever news travel faster and better
is completely directing and then you end
up with such a mess in in education so
that is really that's alarming actually
hopefully you find some other good stuff
to talk now
okay
um
would you like to add on something on
this particular topic
i would like to of course maybe but i
don't want it no no go ahead so what you
just
said i think it
will probably get a little worse now
since um
you rely so much on technology to have
access to science
and
a lot of people don't know that lectures
at the university are actually free to
go to you just need to be enrolled to
take the exam and to get a degree but
you can go to every lecture you like but
now it's more and more difficult because
you need an access link to join a hybrid
class or whatnot so
yeah that's a little bit disturbing so i
didn't get the point that that is
becoming more accessible or less less
successful less successful yeah i see
so
well
of course you know i'm
i'm always interested in the differences
across countries because educational
systems are very much different
in the moment
children learn about science in the u.s
is way way
it's early i mean if you are around palo
alto in those very well-situated
high-tech environments my son had to
learn about it at the age of three or
four and as a good german mother i was
friending about it because i thought
he's way too young
so i mean we can actually learn we need
to be concerned yes but on the other
hand we can learn a lot uh from the
standard deviation across countries
where
people with a low education can be do
better compared to the average and where
they do worse compared to the average
and then adjust educational systems and
this is what we know but what we don't
do right yeah so it's in our hands yes
you can't deny that this has
implications i think
that's actually a very good point that
uh if we're analyzing individual
countries on this we would see
much greater
um deviations
and i think it's relatively homogenized
the way that it's presented in one slide
yes and then we later obviously talk
about causality which is another point
behind those data
yeah um
i guess we might get the chance to talk
about it um a bit later yeah um okay
so we changed the topic now um i'm going
to show you a slide
this is sort of uh
quite something it's really rock setting
here
yeah it's like like
you mean on this tool no no no no no no
because we are asking we are getting
asked so many questions about our
knowledge
[Music]
have you been on the panel before
together no no
otherwise i would be better prepared
i would have answered it with 90 or
something
[Laughter]
okay let's go to this um
this um
i'll tell you this this story here
we have um the the 2018 um
nobel peace uh
nobel prize winner in chemistry uh
george smith
he developed an elegant method known as
a phage display
um
that
that he uses bacteriophages to evolve
new proteins
after winning the nobel he
the nobel prize he came up with some
statements
and they were mostly about the
intellectual property rights uh owned by
pharmaceutical companies and more
specifically i will read the
the text which is written in bold there
to these two questions
did the companies who developed and
produced the covered 19 vaccines deserve
patent monopolies for their vaccines
and was the promise of patent monopolies
the best way for governments to foster
development of the vaccines
his answer
was that
in both questions
he says no
and the reason he says no is because um
this type of work
requires not just a few years that a
pharmaceutical company needs to put on
to create an innovation a patent
but it relies on a whole century um
of innovations of
dozens of different research groups
so he says in the end
that um
a better way to stimulate vaccine
development would have been through
public funding
and
i would like to hear a christian's view
on this and
okay i can see a lot of you smiling
which is
nice
that is
a very complex
matter
it is yeah it is emotional uh and i have
a lot of understanding for that
but i
i would think
i have an empathetic no to his no
and i explain to you why
first i i
think it is very
valid to say that the government should
invest
in in the advance of science for
you know massive health problems that is
undebatable
but i'm on a true belief
that
the efforts
and
the genius of of discovery and
inventions
need to be protected in order to
make it possible to facilitate
innovation
we if you if you allow me to say that if
now we think
the vc and experience the massive impact
of the covet 19 development of certain
companies
but if we deconstruct this in reverse
engineer it took them many years to get
there
and for this they needed a lot of
financial resource investments
yeah some companies worked on the
development of mrna-based vaccines over
20 years
and they had to raise
a lot of money to do this and they could
only access those financial resources
because of private investors who see
their investment in return and they can
only do this if the inventions are
protected otherwise there is no thesis
for any investment so one thing i think
we live in a system where
innovation is protected by intellectual
property which allows it really
enables advancement of innovation
i would also invite us to think if you
consider
some of the most
strongest places of innovation like
think about harvard or mit as a
wellspring of creativity talents and
discoveries and those places uh
are in such a strong position and can
attract talent because of their
infrastructure capabilities environment
brilliant teachers and so forth their
funding is you may not know eighty
percent run by by their uh managing the
intellectual property so the world
depends i think on innovation
and most of our biggest problems haven't
been addressed yet because we haven't
discovered yet enough so we need
innovation but i do think protection of
innovation to drive it forward is very
very important
so i it's really tricky and then i'll
leave you one more um i know you saw two
minutes so be prudent go ahead um i
think it's also not as trivial to
uh
think that you can easily copy in
discoveries in in inventions
so making a covet 19
vaccine the way companies like biontech
have mastered that you cannot just give
a recipe of cooking to someone it's
actually super dangerous what could
happen if it's not available in a
regulated or protected manner because
those scientists those companies
literally worked on this 10 20 years the
indie out
so it is not as trivial to email someone
a recipe i think it's much better to
invest and make the vaccine rapidly
globally you know to everyone available
by investing in companies who have
mastered that so that is i think
that's why it's a complicated matter
but i'm a
true champion of the idea that the world
you're living in
discoveries and invention need to be
protected in order to drive them forward
because the the
the resource created is is a large
fraction is reinvested innovation
it's it's a vicious cycle going forward
if we disrupt this we will pay a price
of innovation for the world i'm
absolutely convinced about that
i would like to emphasize though on his
point
on that particular phrase that
i i i i
understand the way you're expressing i
cannot i cannot i'm not i'm not gonna
take a position myself here as a
moderator so um
but um how do you answer to the fact
that he says that
the actual research
um even though if somebody went from i
don't know
if the journey is from one to ten right
assuming that a pharmaceutically uh
pharmaceutical companies started their
journey from from four to ten and took
it to ten how about
zero to four
um yes what happened there i don't know
where you draw the line it's infinite
it's infinite right because every
everything builds on something we can go
back to your
uh
you know heritage we can go back to
aristotle so carter i don't know where
we start we are one thing created in
another one uh i do think that
the way that you can define
protectable
in inventions is defined by a process
and review of
you know rigor and it is investigated
by an expert panel to say this is an
invention that can be protected
and if everything builds on everything
in life and and i don't think you can
draw a line and say from
you needed to depend on i that doesn't
work for me
okay jonah would you like to comment
yes i can comment on um like two or
three points so
um smith said uh that's a better way to
um
yeah what did you say was a vaccine
as a vaccine development would be
facilitated by funding basic research
right so um of course
funding
basic research is not as easy to get so
as a percentage of
proposals that are actually funded are
rather low among different
panels like dfg if you're lucky is 25
percent or
erc grants
highly competitive so there is a
question maybe ten
five to ten percent
um get the funding and then as the
question whether the
majority of the ideas are not
funding worthy or if
there's just not enough funding
available
yeah so so it wouldn't really work you
think in that way with the public
funding
you you try and try and try to require
funding and um
yeah if
then you get one or two students funded
and so in the position that um at the
universities for instance where these
ideas really
right so this is step one
right of your one to ten scale
and
there should be a little bit more
funding available to um yeah to follow
different ideas
so okay yes
lady please so i think that this is not
necessarily the case i mean you're
absolutely right uh that
we when we look at uh public funding for
science
that we spend more and more and more and
more money for two or three or the
maximum four-year projects
which is of course not the time needed
for to
do a really basic long-term
projects and developments and foster
innovation this needs to be changed and
this is one concern which we have right
now in the coalition building in all the
discourses around getting the ministry
of education and science
that
the project time gets shorter and
shorter
and this also would mean that the public
area is less competitive to private
research which concerns me a lot
what also concerns me is
that we
in part
work on the same issues without knowing
from each other publicly and privately
so it's a question how do you increase
the knowledge
who is working on what
and i would like to come to this point
later in the discussion because this is
all about good uh scientific work then
of course we have the problem that we
really do not invest
enough money in what i or what we call
science policy that we do not enable
poorer countries to come up with those
innovative forces because they simply do
not have the money and therefore we have
to think about this delaware mental
issue as well so not just looking that
they have enough and don't staff but
also that they have the capacities
for doing uh research and this must be
at the front of how we think about those
questions
okay
christian would you like to answer
the two things came to mind when
listening to both of you
one is
you can't be so
descriptive
on funding research because everything
starts with basic research right if you
deconstruct again the the story of
mrnade you know it goes back to the
discovery of the genetic code and how it
translates into the building blocks and
the role of mrna and so forth so this is
all basic research the utility and the
application to do vaccines as an
invention that was protected i actually
really think if it wasn't a practice the
vaccine would not be available today
yeah but
so there has to be a sense of
appreciation and the other one is
of course the private and public has to
work way better together
and it is about the dialogue and
education of society
and
also the industry has to work way better
which we happen to see now in
in the pandemic crisis is the
pre-competitive partnerships people
competitive knowledge sharing data
sharing in the interest of advancing the
science faster so i think as i mentioned
earlier we have a tremendous window of
opportunity here that we don't know
whether we will capture it but it's
right now there and i think discussions
like yours today and catalyze those
well it also means that we
publish
earlier or that open access will be
extended and that we also
let to know each other on what we are
working and what did not work and not
just what works
and all those things you know would
provide more equality in having
the possibility of success
okay we'll we'll come to this topic
about open access of journals in the
following slides um
i would like to
to highlight what um you said christian
with regards to the collaboration which
was much intensified throughout the
covet era
wouldn't it not have been a fantastic
opportunity to do the same for climate
change it was that immediate response
that the whole world had to take to the
pandemic
and for the first time there were there
was no so not so much pattern discussion
there was so much sharing of data
between the public the corporations
everybody and that that worked so so
well
from a macro perspective it worked
really well exceptionally well for the
coveted 19.
if you consider
that in
basically the the virus was uh kind of
first mentioned in december 19 by by
january 2020 we had it sequenced and
within we had um instructions on on
citizens all around the world how to act
um
we could digitalize
where everybody is
um and um
there was a vaccine out in two months
which became official in six months
so this is unprecedented for for human
beings last pandemic 1918 it killed them
millions of people if we had the same
behavior as back in
uh sorry um 19 1918 it was
um
then it would have eliminated most of
the planets today um
so it was a fantastic
expression of collaboration and
let's see whether this can be a
sustainable somehow
well i mean i mean the south virus has
been studied since decades actually i
mean it
wasn't like this
and we had this very famous 2010 paper
telling us about the consequences of the
sars2 virus which nobody took serious i
mean
there are some
okay i i'm i'm generalizing a little bit
but yeah very much
they could have they could have
sequenced it in one day if they wanted
to however right
yeah i mean a couple of things were much
much faster i mean no question about
this but the history of the sas virus is
a very long one
yeah
okay um let's move on to a very similar
topic which is um this example i'm gonna
go through now it's the case of
jacob sims
jacob sims was a patient um back in the
early zeros with the so-called mad cow
disease
this is um otherwise known as
cjd this is a very deadly
neurodegenerative disease you have a
life expectancy of up to a year
and
what his father did at the time
he was able he was somehow he got access
to the latest medical research findings
so he
um
he found out about this drug
pentagon polysulfate
which was at the time used being used
experimentally on animals
and he
he claimed that he wanted to administer
this to his son
and he took it to court and he won the
legal case the drug was given to his son
and the son lived for another 10 years
and he became an ambassador for the an
ambassador for the disease he was the
longest
living patient with a mad cow disease
and this ignited a whole discussion
about open
open science and open access to journals
um so
um
inspired by this example
i would like you to hear your views on
on
open science um
who would like to go first i don't have
any preference
well i would first distinguish between
the diagnosis that this is indeed a
jacob cordsville disease i think this
would be very very hard to find it out
for yourself using the internet
so now the other thing is knowing that
you have this disease
and then it all depends but on the
quality which is published
in the internet so whether or not you
follow strict rules on quality of papers
and things like this
i think this particular case study is is
more about him accessing uh scientific
journals um
and well then i don't have any
reservations about it i just wanted to
make this difference that it's not about
trying to find out and which disease you
have which i think it's much much harder
and then which probably which cure
probably helps or not and this is about
uh
the politics of journals and how they
publish in what they publish and this is
the quality of publication review
processes and all we know about open
data
exactly
when i was doing my phd 20 years ago
everything was locked we had to have
subscriptions for everything
nowadays especially after the covered 19
you know 37 of publications
uh i'm talking about scientific journals
okay
they are open
um
what is your view on this i you know for
us and at buyer this is an incredibly
important topic to have data
transparency and access to data and
information
because you know you have to build uh
the trust
and with this you get confidence in the
work we do for patients
so i think
i think we see in
a lot of
evolution and development in the
direction of open access and
transparency
and that is the
in one way you
you you talk about excess of data
we see now
that
we will get the support from agencies to
get trucks approved based on real world
data evidence and you can only work with
this if you make data
an open access available
so it is a topic yet
you have to maintain
uh
quality of data access you have to take
scientific
integrity of the data you can't just
download
data without providing guidance what the
insights are and what is meaning
of the data
yet i don't think we will good we could
do service and have the
inclusiveness and transparency and trust
of the society of developing medicines
for society without
going the direction of data transparency
in excess we have to involve the
patients if you make medicines for
patients you have to make no medicines
with the patient to bring patients on
board listen to them and that is
often facilitated by data access so it's
a great moment in history of humankind
again that we will change
this
but
um
assuming you do
somehow manage to fund all the journals
and you open up everything there's no
more subscription for science or nature
where whoever um
how do you train
the citizens what difference does it
make to the citizens who are
non-scientists and trained to read the
methodologies and everything um
i will give the the word to uh yola and
then perhaps come back to you yeah so
scientific and non-scientific
communication
really important and
so in the
journals that are hidden behind the pay
wall like nature and science are so
sometimes they're open access
publications but for the open xx uh a
big advocate for open access
publications but the review process
defines if it's good or
same you got work or data
and so the peer review process where
the peers in your fields
comment on your work is very important
and most of the time it should enhance
the quality of the paper that's later
published
and
then the
communication to the not that trained
audience is also important and usually
there are small um excerpts
that describes a work that was published
in the special specific
specialized journal and this becomes
more and more important i think to break
this down that
everybody understands what it's about
and i think
this is much better now
after the war during the
pandemic than it was before
or as you said you experienced the same
it's
yeah
okay thank you
yuta would you like to
well as i said before open access is not
open access you read to develop
standards before you do this and i have
it's a
visit b one researcher his name is
mccarten humphreys who worked together
with others on exactly this topic and
this article has been published already
in
2015 in science calling promoting an
open research culture and there he
really makes the argument for
transparency for openness and for
irreprosibility but under certain
conditions and those conditions
are really very very important because
otherwise you get all this garbage in
the net and this can be really harmful
for people so you have to have this
quality control and you have to have to
incentivize the researchers differently
than we re incentivize our resources in
the moment so not simply publish results
where you find differences but also
those who know differences are found
please give some credits not just for
citations but also for the methods and
for the development and in things like
this i mean this is really a worthwhile
reading paper which is at the very
substance of this discussion of open
science but given that we really handle
this with care which is need not done
everywhere then
of course we have to reverse what
publisher usually get
as
money in selling uh the journals
to the people
who have to pay for their own
research and this shouldn't be done by
out of their own pockets so we need to
think about this in funding uh research
and i do not see much progress on that
may i tell you to build on that i do
think there's a difference between open
access for just information versus
making excess of good information
peer-reviewed
in information otherwise in preparation
of our meeting today
i was introduced to the word infobassity
infobasity and which could be a great
foundation for fake news
and we've seen this in the covert
pandemic where non-peer-reviewed
unexpected or whatever motivated
information has really irritated and had
put people at harman at risk exactly so
i think we have to differentiate between
access to peer-reviewed rigorous and
relevant information but not opening the
gate for i quote you narrator on the
garbage download and creating info
obesity that holds innovation and
science and progress back rather than
accelerating it
so it uh
it is not
you raise great things great topics but
the answer isn't as simple to us yeah
definitely and i don't want to use it as
an excuse
one new direction they're taking um
it used to be the peer review used to be
done by
usually two
two reviewers um for per per article
the newest
news direction is to to let it open and
be reviewed by the scientific community
um also another direction is to
pre-publish
as you said to show the methodology
right before you get the results that
you want um so you you get um
this is even more fair i think that um
you develop a methodology which is um
reviewed along the way
yola would you like to say something
before we leave the topic
no
let me just because this fits so very
nicely i mean it's not just
pre-published i mean this means that a
paper is accepted in that i publish it
before the journal comes out i mean this
is what we understand with
pre-publishing no it's showing the
methodology before it's actually going
to be published or not
exactly and sharing that you are working
on particular issues this i find very
important because then you find out
which other uh you know groups or
whatever the chi is working on a similar
or is applying for money to work on a
similar topic than other groups
worldwide and this i think will
intensify innovation considerably
not keeping the secret yeah
i prefer open access peer-reviewed
articles
over
pre-publishing yeah i think this is
worth it to wait for the reviews what
your peers think about the work and um
otherwise there's really a lot and it's
very difficult even for experts to just
extract
things and then afterwards if you may
find an interesting
seminal pre-published work and
yeah then you need to keep track um what
the final article actually looks like
and it might change a lot exactly yeah
this is why the nobel prizes went in
economics went to exactly those people
to which they went because they were
making those calls
claims that
much of our research is simply wrong
because it shows uh
correlated but not causal effects which
can be hugely harmful in particular in
medicine
okay sorry no it's fine um let's let's
since you already mentioned it let's
move on to the topic of info obesity
so
basically let's define
info obesity a little bit here for our
audience
it's a relatively new word and it means
it's a concept of of information
overload
when all data is open and accessible by
anyone anywhere at any time
mainly through social media channels
when one has too much information he or
she cannot always filter out the right
information for effective decision
making
or cannot focus on what is meaningful
for their specific purpose
and also it's very likely to create
fake news
let's also see on this slide
the
sources of information according to the
euro barometer
so
you can see that 63 is coming from
television or
streaming
um so
that's
that's one
the main pillar
the second one is social media and then
you have
14
radio
and podcasts and 13 online encyclopedias
so um
let's let's talk about the danger of
into obesity and the generation of fake
news especially since we agree um
on open
science and journals so okay we're
providing the scientific facts let's see
how we can protect
our audiences
well i mean
if you watched uh television or if you
in particular if you watch television or
tv or whatever you see more and more
that they refer to the sources and the
data and that they even sometimes
provide access to the data so that you
can replicate it this is a big
progress which has been made over the
last couple of years and
therefore i'm not very surprised about
this
well those 14 ratio including podcasts
is very very low
compared to 29 online social networks
but at the other hand i thought that
online social networks is much much
higher
because this in particular creates this
overload
which by the way uh
in my opinion
this is the highest danger of this is
that you
lose trust in science because you do not
know whom to follow and therefore you do
not follow anyone and you do this what
is worst for science that you think that
there is no truth that there is no right
answer and uh this is sort of the end of
all
i think the the
what you mentioned the key word trust is
a very important element
there's a lot of studies
that um
are showing that
people for example the people who don't
vaccinate
is because necessarily they don't have
access to data
in fact they all have access to data
it's because
they haven't been influenced by somebody
they trust
and this is this is how
people are misled quite frequently um
if somebody they trust is on the wrong
track
uh then they can be
they follow him
um
i would like to to i can see you nodding
a lot christmas
we know all what we're talking about
we've been a situation where someone you
know uh there's a lot of access to
people
advice that if you drink detergent or
put it into your veins you'll get rid of
covet i mean this is a danger i think
right now we will learn how to uh
regulate this too i do i do think this
there will be a
development of how
we
citizen society and regular governments
deal with people that
unconstrained
make fake information for people at risk
we see it already
happening but you imagine rita and when
you are in in the business and
the purpose of making medicines
then it is incredibly important to have
an
approach of
false information and one is building
trust and that comes back to how you
include society and patients in your
work how you have open access to data
will they listen more to you because you
have
trust and i think i have the privilege
to be part of a company of 150 almost
160 years of
contributing important medicines to
humankind i think there's an element of
trust but we have to leverage this to
our purpose to help people to understand
but i'm massively concerned if
information comes out and advises people
who suffer someone from cancer
or someone from covert then it's
misguided and and risks lives
so
there needs to be again an approach to
this
and you can't prevent it or avoid it but
i think you can
steer it in into in the favor
yeah and i think we need to have a
collective approach to this
to build this trust
and you're like i think it's
very important to
focus on where to pick up the person
that's interested in certain information
because they can easily get frustrated
if it's too high level which does not
mean by any means that they are stupid
and will never understand it's just you
need to break it down and start at a
different point or rephrase it and
i guess
that's
done in television there is like
different
levels of uh information that they
provide with a podcast you are
usually if you subscribe you are have a
interest prior to subscribing so it's
more specialized
yeah
um you wanted to add something well i
just wanted to make a little make it
even worse because it's not just about
losing trust in science it's also trust
in losing
it's also
the possibility that you lose trust in
politics
and this is even worse and
this all brings us back to communication
and explaining
why you handle things as you do handle
this why in state one
people can go to school in stage two
people can't go to school why children
have to wear masks at school and adults
don't have to wear masks and and all
those things which we are not very well
explained
so we need to
have many more people like you do it's
multifactorial i agree yeah
thank you
it's multifactorial the whole topic
and the the politics is something that
we cannot hide
i think in my opinion there's two um
elements one is you need to have
you need to train the audience
if they know about scientific reasoning
and failure and success
when you come out in in
march 2020 and you tell them i would
like you to all wear gloves
so
the government bought tons of gloves and
then three months later oh sorry it
wasn't gloves it was masks that you
should be wearing
and the scientists can say that because
they have collected data and found out
that gloves
do not work really they don't do very
much but masks do and if if you are
trained on this and you see the data
you're going to be convinced
okay you know science is dynamic but
then comes the government who bought
tons of gloves
throughout the the first three months
and they want and they also probably um
align with some corporations that
produce um gloves uh this is a fictional
example by the way i'm using
not very much so but
yeah some stuck up uh detergent
certainly
yeah so so exactly and then you have
politics intervening with science um
that you have to wear both masks and
gloves until the gloves run out
in which case you can wear only the mask
um
anyway you will you will like this
you'll find this i think i found it
fascinating in in the euro but i'm going
to read it to you now is on this topic
three in 10 people believe in conspiracy
theories such as the idea that viruses
have been produced in government
laboratories
to control our freedom
um
and there's another one that there is
the cure the same study i haven't got in
my notes that there is a cure for cancer
but we don't they don't show it to us
three out of the ten people out of the
thirty
thirty seven thousand
europeans being uh questioned on these
believe um
uh in conspiracy theories so
it's not easy to say oh yes but it's not
me well it's not you but it's a
it's 30 of the population is your
neighbor
so um
this is an init kind of um
urge for human beings to create
conspiracy theories and i think there is
an evolutionary basis on this
the but it's not a no it's not an issue
to discuss uh right now but based on
this we have to protect very much
uh since there is this tendency we have
to protect the citizens somehow and this
brings me to the following question
which is exactly this
which is
how can we create um
an active
role for um
citizens
okay let's take all this what we've said
so far into practice
so
i would like to be more specific in my
question
we often talk about science research and
data feeding into citizens but could we
actually reverse the equation
can we offer citizens
an active role in science policies
research and innovation and if yes
how
i would start with you this time yeah i
think
nobody ever should just stop to ask
questions
so always ask why why why this is what
brought me into science as a
theater with us why why is that and now
i'm thinking about electrons and atoms
and um
yeah it's
important that you not get frustrated
what i said before but
just
change the perspective and the angle and
keep asking until you really understood
what you wanted to know
this this
is very nice but
how do you cultivate this
so um you can encourage this for
instance at a university it doesn't need
to be a frontal lecture where we just
keep
telling the students what they should
know but ask questions and check if they
really got you
and this is something that you can
always do like if somebody approaches
you and asks a question sometimes you
see in their eyes like okay they stop
listening and they don't understand and
you need
to yeah find a way a
mutual level for communication and
this is a challenge on both sides
thank you christian well i i thought the
answer to this in part is where you
started with the when you shared some
facts from the survey
in part it can be addressed by investing
in education because when you are
informed
uh i think you have greater interest and
you you didn't know how to deal with
this data the other one is
how we uh
uh also from a from a
you know
company perspective how we work together
with
the audience that is so much of interest
to our scientists and patients
are they included in our process why do
we share the data again
can can patients be part of
our work more can we
academics or industry have to get out of
their
ivory tower silo thinking
and see and leverage this and the
importance and then working with
journalists because where is the
difference communicating science between
facts and fictions
can we be in a better partnership
together will you get our interest as
much as will you reach out
but i do think it is a
responsibility that includes almost
everyone governments
the the private part the journalists uh
you know we have to have an in ethos and
we have to have i think increased
standards uh moral and scientific
rigor and standards and communication
it's a responsibility and and so i would
reach out and say can we share
an adhere to our standards of
communicating science and and data and
facts
thank you but i would like to make it a
bit more tangible
um we want citizens to get involved into
science policy
somehow they want this is what they
answer in all surveys
um
and it's more fair if they also have a
say into that how do we do that
well
first of all you have to
lay laser groundwork of all of this and
assign more hours in schools
for for science
i mean this i think it's
it's most necessary we do not learn
about
the basic elements of science at schools
in germany at least and
this needs to be changed and by this we
can enable
people much more than we do right now
and this also means
that we uh
reach more people and engage them in
education and at least in germany we
lose uh each year twenty percent uh and
it increased the number who do not get
over a very basic level of
education and
so this also means that and should i
should have started differently
we still do not really understand which
people
misbelief in science and why they tend
to conspiracy theories so i think that
we have to research it much more why
this happened and then of course we can
increase
the our spending teaching them about
science at school
in further education and things like
this we in can increase
the way we bring signs to the people and
not just waiting until they come to a
museum or to the social science center
or listen to talks and things like this
i mean this is a
minority of people who is getting the
information about this and you showed
this figure uh before so uh and it if i
think about my fields i mean we
have surveys huge surveys this euro
barometer which you showed i mean it's a
huge survey
but do we really bring back
the answers all those people gave us
and the time they spent for us getting
all those results bringing those results
back to the people no we don't do that
and so there's a lot of things which
well i mean if i would do a survey then
i could publish sort of the aggregate uh
what all those people are responding is
but
it's it's entirely unlikely that i share
my results with them but they're out
they're open they're they're published
but yeah but but i'm usable my institute
works a lot on my creation and
integration and we're going to know
colin in all those areas where we find
many many people coming from all over
the world
we ask them about their experience and
things like this and then we have
thousands of data and they are published
in peer-reviewed journals we are not
going to know
and then presenting their own data
gathered by them
with their time
so that they are informed about their
own results and see
that they all you know sort of differ
that they are not sharing the same views
on things and we do not bring them to
talk together if they are of different
opinions and things like this so we can
do much more bringing our results back
to those people who were provided us
with our numbers and shared their time
with us
and this is in many areas a case and i
think it would be a wonderful example to
to increase
thought not just
the way
scientists and citizens interact but
also increase the trust they have in us
are you aware of the um
citizen science movement um sure
i mean we are doing i mean my
my profession is doing a lot of citizen
science because we are entirely
dependent on people answering our
surveys
okay this is a yeah this is this is
considered to be one way of engaging um
your audience only if you bring the data
back to them because otherwise it's a
form of exploitation sorry that i say
this so
hot okay uh what do you think about
citizen science what's your view um
christian
i mean as an enormous opportunity right
to uh raise the awareness and and
and invite people in that space and and
i think this is exactly i was thinking
you mentioned education is done by uh
streaming and internet but you know it
would be great if kids could from time
to time see an advertisement on
the coolness of science versus another
coca-cola advertisement or you know that
soccer playing or you know at least in a
balanced way you know uh
that people the kids could ask questions
uh why is this show and why is this cool
uh
so uh you know we and we um with the
bayer foundation are involved in those
movements
because obviously it's the next
generation
for us from a sustainability perspective
is incredibly important we will run out
of existence if we don't find the next
cool scientist
you know supporting us in our efforts to
make medicines
i think it might not be the solution to
increase the hour of
stem subjects in school but to
really start teaching as a pupils um how
to
approach any questions they like in a
scientific manner
yeah that's that's yeah that's a very
nice replication things like what are
the standards of doing good science and
at least i did not have this at school
it's still not covered
yeah neither did i and from a personal
perspective i was taught um you know in
physics oscillations on a blackboard um
it was never a kind of um explain to me
why are we learning that um and how does
this relate to a bridge you're crossing
with your car and it moves
um there was never any
connection of science to real life and
this is what we're trying to do with
our work here and it's not just the
we're not trying to to shift all the
teenagers that we're working on
uh to to become
engineers and and doctors or physicists
but we're trying to cultivate
a the scientific method as a way of
living of challenging things
um
would it be fair to say that you know
right now we have three four major
challenges climate change
uh hunger
and diseases
and maybe you can add one or two but all
of them can only be uh addressed by
science think about that
the major issues of humankind can only
be addressed by by science
so to conclude or on our kind of
[Music]
views about engagement of citizens
i'll try and sum up what you've said
education is very important at schools
um
also
open access
to scientific journals um
and citizen science but when this is
done
in a um
in a right way that you train them
throughout the experiment they learn
throughout the procedure and they
collect data
in order to be part of an experiment
that they understand as well and there
was a there was a publication
i think a couple of years ago that
together with the five six seven authors
they also put the 500
people who collected the data in the
authors which was very nice
to um
to acknowledge their contribution so
we're moving towards the end now um
and
two more things one would like some
questions
from you or um i don't know whether we
can get any any online
but
are there any questions that you would
like
um
us to answer
please isabella
um i have a couple questions
thank you
thank you i have a couple questions um
first of all i would like to
to you to repeat the person who write
who wrote that article about open
science i would love to read up about
that
and the second is
i think i would even put it harder as
you for almendinger with
citizen science i don't think it's
necessary not only to collect data and
give back to the people what they've
what they said but
to
what we really want to do is to raise
critical thinking
in
by
by activating people by
being part of even the design of these
studies or you know what are the
questions we're asking and what are the
the problems we're trying to solve
so um get people into the process at a
very early stage
until the end when the when the um
results are published yeah so as to your
second point i entirely agree so this is
what we usually do we have those focus
groups and we learn
in what ways they think about its
entrance we transform it into questions
and then we ask those questions but then
we do not do the very last step usually
sorry for interrupting
in one uh study of vtb and i was
actually informed of the i know
that was a good example
and the the other question is thank you
if you don't mind isabella nice meeting
you hi um
in let other participate in in studies
and you may be disappointed if i share
with you that is relatively recently
not only at bayer but we do you know
right now when we do clinical trials
study designs for testing the potential
new medicines
now patients are invited into this
process
patient foundations are being asked is
this the right thing to do is this is
what you're really looking for can we go
faster can we go better how would we
make the the
studies open to to the patients in need
and it hasn't been like this
yeah it was decided somewhere else but
right now it is this open access is this
invitation if it's done for you we need
to do it with you and this is a really
new experience
that's good that's a good intro to my
question which is to you
you've been proposing open data
to share patients information so
patients should share their information
and be part of the process
um on the starting end however on the
other hand you're asking for
um or you're voting for knowledge
protection at the same time so how does
that fit together
i see i see you know i see a problem
there with open data and knowledge
protection you can't really
you can't combine them in my views so i
do think that when you
thanks for for allowing me to
perhaps
clarify that to you when
when you see knowledge p protection
doesn't mean you're not sharing
right it's just that you protect
that when you have
made efforts
and you have differentiate yourself from
from others that you you have a chance
to protect your
you know your own progress your your
discovery your invention
but a patent is as rapidly made
available
by knowledge sharing as a publication
so knowledge is not shared
and
it's not prevented not to share this is
a misconception that your information
that is intellectual property is
protected by the mechanism or patent
it's not sitting somewhere and you can't
access it not at all it's actually
better and more detailed often shared
with any scientific publication
um but you're right
in when we work with patients and we
need that data there's an element of
course also from from
a patient's information protections
so how can you i would almost in a
dialogue with you
if the patient needs to be involved and
we need information how could this
information from a specific patient can
be shared back into
in into the public domain
and i i don't know how we feel about it
but i have to say
that in germany for instance is almost
virtually impossible
to share patients data in order to
advance science there are other
countries way more progressive because
for the common shared goal between a
patient
between a company who has medicines and
between society there is a shared goal
of you know how can we progress with
this information some governments
regulated that we don't actually
leverage enough
information so we are in our own way we
have the ambition we talk about it but
we can't walk the talk in certain
countries in certain regions where data
information is prohibited
and i don't think it makes any sense
because the patient actually wants to
participate and share information but
it's not allowed to pass that on is i
think it's a huge bottleneck
okay
i'm sure you're dealing with this um
from from the politics and from
policymakers i really don't
can get really emotional on this that i
don't understand vice or society doesn't
uh support sharing information on
diseases on
certain patients in particular medicine
today is so personalized
you know we
every patient has almost his own disease
and we will only understand this by
sharing this information
in germany for instance
it's virtually impossible
yeah this is another important topic i
think um next year invite us again
please we will we will spend another
hour and a half on it's great that we
got a question here okay
thank you
um any other questions we have time to
take one more
that's the article yeah
[Music]
if we could go back to the slide you
presented on access
on axis
and in this respect if i understood
correctly yuta you said that the
educational systems are so different
from country to country is that correct
well that one thought well
there is a lot of
not to this
to this
so here education plays an important
role
in the outcomes of the eurostat
yep
would it mean that if education differs
from country to country the results of
the eurostat would differ from country
to country yes indeed it is this is
clearly the case
because i know the german numbers and
the german numbers look quite different
from those numbers those are the
aggregate numbers of all
uh otd countries and of course i mean uh
it's always a question whether you trust
an average or not or what an average
means yeah so in fact we have a real
view it should be
broken down by country yes but not only
by country but also by uh age because
younger people trust more in science
than older people
and then
of course by
we have seen this before oh yeah yeah
it's exactly this
and now to christian uh the next slide i
think is
we if you go to the next slide yes this
one
i think i have bad news because
if i
know correctly
the development of the vaccine has been
supported through public funding
yes
so this is not
really true what mister said not all
private money which so
so no no sorry the question is yes
what would you say
that
the royalties have been collected by the
company
while it has been supported by public
money
so so i would say so that the situation
is worse than
uh
to be it would have been better to
develop it by
through public funding because it was
developed by partly by public public
funding but the benefits are
are reaped completely by the company
is that correct and what would you say
about this yeah so there is um
i have to acknowledge this and thank you
for bringing it up um there is a
situation in the in the u.s
where the nih
very early on recognized that the
development of the vaccine
could be accelerated by providing more
resources
that's indeed the case
and it's underputable that this has
created a situation where public funding
accelerated under the circumstances of
the pandemic crisis
yet
that
the discovery
of
the vaccine technology of this company
moderna was not funded by the nih it was
once the
medicine has proven to be relevant or
has a chance to succeed the nih stepped
in
and accelerated the development
by
their funding which is in part in part
public funding so it is indeed the case
that under the circumstance of pandemic
the the government the nih stepped in to
help developing the
the medicine
as much as uh you know the partnership
between pfizer and in and biontech and
and companies
like you know the partnership
and providing
yeah i think i completely does it work
i completely see this but the question
is if public funding goes ultimately
into
private benefit
of the company yeah
in one way or another
well i is this something to be
condemned or not
i do think that the
which was absolutely the right thing to
do the decision of the government in the
nih to step in and to say let's not
waste time
was not
to help the company in this case moderna
to become faster more profitable it was
that how could we support that this
medicine goes to to the u.s citizens and
beyond
so their interest was
it wasn't a dialogue between moderna and
the government can we make moderna
growing faster and better it was you
know with the resource that the company
didn't have but the u.s has can we put
your muscles to play to provide those
medicines faster but i do think it is a
a situation that is not as
straightforward here i i agree with you
here
thank you i would have to uh interrupt
here because we have um
i would like to give to our three
panelists um a minute to state a wish
which is in an ideal world
how would you envision
science's role in society
so this is a closing statement um
and i would like to start with you yola
um yeah i would wish that
the perception of scientists does isn't
linked to an academic title but
also those
that
are not at university so consider
themselves scientists
and develop
yeah very well
scientific methods
and background checks if i can convert
this in other words if we
continue being babies
because all babies are scientists
yes yes they are so curious they do they
are experimental they are curious and
then comes the education system
which this
um
starts to close off this experimentation
with everything
and this is how creativity is um
diminished
right that was beautiful but i mean a
little bit irritated it seems like a lot
of me i haven't grown up
um
yeah
please i i would
say that what we've seen right now it's
uh
hopefully that
this continues the interest in science
the interest in science the respect for
the efforts
and the shared understanding that as i
said you know what are we really facing
and
as big problems
and diseases and the vulnerability of
human
is to stays very high and the only way
to combat it and overcome it is by
show interest learn about it and have
respect
the effort and time it takes and how
little we know let's be all humble
how little we know and how vulnerable we
are
and science is the only way to deal with
that
this is why it's so cool to be in a
panel with
um such a high caliber speakers because
you hear these messages
now um
it is your turn well science is still
not very inclusive we have to
increase the diversity both by social
background of where people come from and
that they have much more chances to
really become scientists
we have to increase
internationality and we also think to
increase the number of women in science
or this is very clear and we didn't do
very good on this
second we have to prepare people much
better in upcoming crisis and to uh
enable them to live according to their
standards we are doing a lot of research
where we see that people know about this
climate crisis but they don't really
know what to do themselves
day for day for day and here we have to
teach them much more enabling that they
can live up to the standards they have
and this also refers to digitalization
if we don't tell them which jobs will
last for the five 10 more years then
they draw back and become miserable and
do not trust
in anyone anymore so prevention uh is is
really an enabling and
stop to be arrogant
i think we are too arrogant we are not
really listening to those people and why
they distrust us we don't even try to
understand
where their and what their problems are
thank you
i hope that this uh discussion pilot is
more than just the uh
the uh a conversation i hope this is the
beginning of something that um
can't have somehow a future it's it's
something that it's nice to discuss from
a theoretical point of view but
something needs to be done
and i um i wish
that uh we couldn't do something to
continue in this
so at this moment i would like to thank
very much our three guests yuta thank
you for challenging us here with all
those lights
thank you
christian
and i would also like to uh thank dr
carl collins yes the invitation
he
first envisioned this and of course
my colleague pandora sifnotti
who uh who was uh
and all of you for coming to attend here
so thank you very much and um
have a good night thank you
thank you
[Music]
you